everybody who's worked at center live um
pretty much everybody does a lauren
michael's impression we've all worked
for him
obviously a great man a huge influence
on all of us but
you do for my money one of the very best
lorne michael's impressions and you do
one specific
just like looking at the oyster crackers
as looking for oyster crackers
burlington you do one of lauren when you
took a flight with lauren is that right
yeah i flew with lauren to the from new
york
uh to la after a show so we did the snl
and we were like good night and then it
was like we had a rush
to get on up get on his his plane
uh to uh
uh la for the emmys and i was on the
plane with seth myers and fred armisen
and i go i've never been
on a on lauren's plane before this is
really exciting they're like yeah yeah
you know you should sit in the back with
him
and i was like really oh wow
you know and so i sat down with lauren
and and he talks like he tells you
everything about silent live and it's
the coolest thing but i was so exhausted
and he talked the entire time and he'd
be like and
that man was chevy chase
then you wake up and you'd be like and
dick ebersole said you know it's really
your show
[Laughter]
you wake up and it's like and ray
charles said they all owe me money
you wake up and he's like that's how you
grow blueberries in maine
sun is coming up and i'm looking back
and
and there's fred and seth sleeping all
peacefully and i'm like
oh gosh this is going to be a quiz you
know like
now when did chevy leave bill
[Laughter]
how do you grow blueberries how do you
grow the blueberries
you mashed in with your feet that's why
he can eject you from the plane yeah
uh seth rogan's coming on the show
tomorrow i know you've worked with uh
seth
a lot
they did it but they're masked you
couldn't hear it uh yeah
yeah do you uh do you have any
impressions of seth he must have worked
with him
i know you have in many films and um
yeah seth i remember
when we did super bad i i was like oh i
like to wear glasses because i used to
get
uh we played cops in that movie and i
was always uh
um i was i we we get uh what you call it
not arrested but messed with by when i
was growing up
by this cop and you wore glasses and
when a cop wears glasses you're just
kind of like
okay you just it's i don't know there's
somebody copping glasses and i was like
oh i'd like to wear
glasses and then it becomes a thing
where they bring out the glasses and
they're showing me
this whatever i tried on so many glasses
and then i go what should i wear and
seth they go well seth what do you think
he's like i really don't give a [ __ ]
he can literally wear like whatever
he wants
it makes zero difference
to me i mean no one cares so yeah
uh now a lot of uh movies with seth were
with uh were judd apatow films
yeah and so yeah he's trying to coax a
little judd apatow out of you i mean
people know his movies and judd gets out
there and he does stand up and stuff so
people are getting to know
learn his rhythm yeah judd judd was
always
like uh yeah i was in a train wreck and
with him and he would just write
judd's steak is he always you say
something to him and he goes oh that's
funny
now that's funny that's very funny he
sounds like he's had a cold since he was
two years old
and he's always like oh that's funny
that's funny i like that that's good
yeah that's good
and then he'll say like you know his
answer to everything he's like you know
what the interesting thing is
you just want to see how [ __ ] up you
are
you know
and amy schumer were like right yeah
just like how just
totally
little air coming out of his mouth a
little air coming out yeah his death
rattle will be like
lost the death was exactly a
you do an impression that no one does uh
and he's been with us
for so long and he's such an icon but no
one does him because he's very specific
alan alda
oh yeah i did alan alda i did more
impressions here than my snl audition
yeah what is happening so far you're
doing pretty well
by the way when we when we go to dinner
this is what it's like
you know i'm just like ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
lauren talking about serial killers
you know the thing about john wenger
the thing about john wayne gaze always
said thank you
oh he did uh allen all that i did uh
auditioning
colin jose wrote a sketch where i was
alan alda auditioning
for biff and back to the future and i
was like uh
hey uh hey why don't you make like a
tree and get out of here
[Laughter]
i got i gotta tell you this is a great
this is just great i i love this it's a
great movie
that's such a great impression no one
does that by the way
yeah peter sarah finnowitz does a pretty
good one but yeah yeah that's but
i met him once and he was like hey you
could do my adr and i was like
no now you did something
for us once and it was so great
you don't have to do it i just loved it
it was one of my favorite things you did
which was a
impression of a dying tauntaun
and uh again it's not required yeah and
i get it
you had me do it you've had me do that
more than once
george lucas is at home like
from me ah they know it all of them
there you see that they all knew it
you know bert lancaster they didn't know
honey take the cigar out of your mouth
[Laughter]
sorry but at taunton tomton kind of goes
like this
and then it goes
when it dies
uh bring your a is on hbo
you